everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina here to bring you this
week's review of arrow season 2 episode
16 Suicide Squad after weeks months
Diggle finally has something to do
besides go to dated breath yeah instead
of making going to deliveries from big
belly burger and other things he finally
has something to do in this week's
episode an exciting episode and
anticipated episode first impressions um
you know I love this episode again like
you know we love Diggle we all want to
do something and he was basically the
focus of this episode and i got it made
it was definitely one of the stronger
episodes disease I loved it I mean it's
also one of the first episodes where we
don't get any flashbacks to the island
no we got flashbacks there to Diggle you
know during the war with his ex-wife who
makes an appearance is also maybe some
of you recognize her from the walking
dead she played the governor's uh you
know temporary girlfriend for a while
yeah so I guess he heard of course the
big introduction when everybody wants to
talk about is Laurel know what uncle
gets her later but Suicide Squad yeah so
what'd you think about the introductions
of Suicide Squad you know it was fun man
and like we're watching this episode and
one of the first thoughts that came in
mind it was like this could be its own
show yeah like it's that good over
shield it was so good like almost
immediately I became invested in the
characters like just everything about
him like I really cared about dead Shawn
this guy was an ass yeah maybe a couple
of appearances which servers like little
boys oei wall about it's like the
dynamic right so good it was there you
know it's early but it's like man this
could be amazing it's a good group in
the chemistry works i mean does you have
you know we got cynthia addai-robinson
as as the head to get her as amanda
waller and everybody else we do get a
little sneak of course there was want to
talk about little Harley Quinn great
voiceover sounds performs just like the
the video of the from the batman the
animated series back in the day so I
know we're gonna see her service team
that we saw in the big reveal trailer a
couple weeks ago of her walking out with
her pigtails and was like I said harley
quinn and so we now know that that's
going to be her but we didn't see her
this episode she was you know travela
they locked her away but everybody else
was great just like their own little
team and we almost forgot about Oliver
yeah
and all of his stuff even though that
was good too it was a very Diggle
centric episode which I'm fine with yes
um my only gripe in and I don't know how
you feel about this but like I thought
Amanda Waller you know she's she's good
I like her as Amanda Waller but I just
felt like I guess I think of like that
old-school Amanda Waller oh she's a
little on the heavier side but it's not
just that just the personality she has
his commanding presence like she's a
hard ass she's cold-blooded yeah and I
just don't quite get that from her I
mean you know I mean it's I just feel
like she doesn't have that commanding
presence but i'd like to see with the
matter when I grant if she's only
appeared in like a handful of episodes
so far so I mean you want to give her
character time she go you know maybe
make a few tweaks who knows but you know
I still like her also have a little bit
of a bias towards her because of
spartacus and I know that she you know
fellows ever seen spartacus she is a
warrior woman like I know she has all
that in her so I'm a little biased
seeing her for like three years on that
show that's just it i didn't watch
spartacus oh maybe that's just the side
i haven't seen right so I'm movin you
know she's gonna get more to do and I
mean it's so much going on seven so I
gotta gotta stay focused can't tempted
to just jump around like crazy gotta
stay focused so we have Suicide Squad
yeah we have their mission we have a su
squad member who's now got his head
blown up shrapnel shrapnel line please
Lady Bracknell boobs ever hey you know
yeah so no he might be making room for
Harley Quinn yes you could join the
score now you know I liked a diggle's
struggle to kind of what you didn't he
was hesitant to to get in with the group
he's got this moral high ground thing
going as I those guys are murders like
yeah but you and Oliver kill people ever
used to kill people yeah you know and
he's saying I'm different than you and
now he's kind of in the end on their
side a little bit more yeah what's
definitely a darker take unlike you know
a super team right you know what I mean
and that's he struggles with that some
of my favorite moments over what we're
watching him interact with Deadshot this
has gotta kill your brother yeah you
know and like there's a scene when a
dead shot basically saying you know this
is my way out you know this you know I
don't care if I die this you know and uh
he's like no I mean I I saw something in
Deadshot that I didn't see from you know
Amanda Waller like his other name his
girlfriend's wife actually I can
remember name yeah and so you know and I
like that cuz I mean how could you not
one like strangling I killed it killed
your brother but it's like yeah you can
see them kind of struggling with that
you know that
good and bad you know and so like I said
this was a divil centric episode but
Oliver was in it Sarah was in there
Laurel love triangle CW has got to have
the love triangle as we say every week
so those were some nice moments I mean
basically I think in the end Oliver just
came to terms with that he can't do this
alone of course nothing really happened
significant with I mean until the very
end of course we will get to that but in
terms of you just realized that like he
needs Laurel he needs Sarah he can't be
distant you know and all that he needs
his friends to help him because Deadshot
is one step ahead maybe ten SEPs he said
this all these years to plan his revenge
yeah it was always on the background
exactly and Oliver sorry yesterday he
said oh that's right and I was just
discovering all this so he's really
playing catch up to that stroke you know
um yeah I just thought it was a really
solid episode III like again and I was
talking on severy week and I guess like
I'm still waiting to see Roy yeah they
mentioned Roy that he's off watching
over a Thea but that's all we get and
again it's like there's so much going on
I understand you know you don't want to
rush into it but it's just something i'm
like really geeking out for like i
really want to see you know right and
then I guess we'll go you know move
towards the end here looking at Oliver
saying I have to go visit an old friend
and I'm writing are like well who's that
gonna be so Amanda Waller don't don't
though don't do it dude another low now
it's like a love square maybe I don't
know I mean I like you kind of gives
them that look saying like or you still
mad at me he's like your lower on my
list or something so we don't know quite
the connection between Oliver and
Cynthia's characters so willed to see
where that go five years on the island
there's a lot though you know to talk
about because I'm sure I don't know I
was not dead but I'm sure like that
story's kind of you know suming may be
over with and move to something else
another chapter right and then looking
ahead next we've got the birds of prey
finally next week not two weeks from now
on every twenty oh great cw-x a lot of
breaks so we get the birds of prey so
what's her name is coming back all overs
Eccleston Huntress is coming back of
course birds of prey is Huntress Black
Canary we looked this up Oracle I don't
know with the Gotham series I don't know
if we're gonna see enter on its color
and offal see oracle or maybe i'll have
a different characters Oh Laurel is a
computer
maybe uh maybe a felicity oh good me I
know or click on the comm explicit he's
not you know I know it's Barbara Gordon
but pretty much TV there's only alright
leaks maybe you know the Gotham serial
what's gonna happen with that so we also
did see that image of Laurel kind of
like in this fighting stance yeah
managers right no we've said this before
about her being black canary a lot of
you guys think that maybe she doesn't
have to be and that's cool too with a
Black Hawk girl maybe your own oh yeah I
just think that you know she wouldn't be
on the show just exist there's a reason
why she's there whether you like or not
with it something stupid she's there for
a reason so maybe she'll be part maybe
not take over for black in here maybe
she'll be a part of birds of prey
somehow movie Felicity could be the
Oracle I don't know maybe not a littles
we'll see where that goes she can't
replace Barbara Gordon but you know so
there's a lot going on there's still a
lot to wrap up so characters we haven't
seen again know a couple that's every
week I think it's important to bring it
up so no Malcolm Merlyn since you know
Moira scared oh and Moira made an
appearance motors got some internet city
swimming programs he's working on solely
thank goodness like I know some people
talk about her mayoral ship her running
for mayors a little bit ridiculous but
at least they mentioned it you know
little kids think about the kissing all
of it is somebody think about the
children so we got to see her Wow summer
glau where we're summer glau i feel like
i'm trying to think back to liz i mean i
know she was ahead pathak some of the
cast you had her brother firefly on this
episode at least she should have showed
up but she didn't it just seemed like
she was talked about a lot going into
this I don't think it may be correct us
if you know you guys pay attention
sometimes a little more than we do it
last time we saw her was a Russian
episode when I think I saw her I think
she paid an episode just after that was
a party at IHS right yeah party but then
that was it not only weeks ago and stuff
so it's again it's like you wouldn't
hype a character like this up or an
actor coming on to show like this just
to like you know forget about her
halfway through the season so she's
gonna play a role she's got to and we
only have however many episodes left but
she'll come back yeah we're almost done
i think maybe five so yeah yeah maybe
like five or six that were almost done
so another great episode you know
Suicide Squad us in the books hard needs
to be a show that needs yeah would you
rather see I know something don't like
us comparing the shows but agents of
shield vs. Suicide Squad I know
man that's just again one episode and I
care more about these guys right and
agents of shield and again it's not fair
to good enough but that's just how we
feel right so I mean you know let us
know which thought tonight's episode
maybe talk about you know we saw the
flash suit was revealed like last week
or so like the full the full suit got to
see that that's coming out later on 2014
in the fall we got so many good things
coming out right now we got birds of
prey next week you know we'll be here of
course I was always going to chat with
us to think hero calm also on this
YouTube page here make sure you
subscribe like comment below you know my
can I try to get to your comments and
you know responders many people as we
can that's gonna be at think euro-pro
we're also on Twitter how to dennis
michael or myself you know keep bugging
dennis about getting on the show here's
what she is catching up so go easy on
them and that's at think hero i'm at
griffin de and i'm at mr. michael Alexis
we also had a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans the
world of social media spread arrow love
everywhere it needs to be heard such a
great show we'll see you back next week
and thanks for tuning in
you